Jersey shore misconnections manger.
I feel like Jersey shore was made for misconnections.
Wow. This one is so Jersey. Cause he's using stuff in quotes. How stuff is it?
How Jersey's it to use stuff in quotes?
Let's help each other red bank.
Any ladies? Quote unquote, what you like, you mean? Hey,
do you mean dudes? If ladies is in quotes,
you mean dudes dressed as ladies? Any ladies intro, intro,
interested in a weekly arrangement,
quotes where we help each other inquiring minds want to know,
do not contact me when unsolicited services, our office.
Any ladies interested in a weekly arrangement? Amen. Just say you want, I mean,
why are you acting like you're not ordering a.
Let's go to another one here. So Jersey to use quotes for no reason.
Male looking for male Eaton town,
just a regular guy here looking for another regular guy to hang out with.
Shoot me an email. Let's talk through NACA says sad.
Email.
Shoot me an email. If you want to be buddies, Hey,
just a guy here over in Eaton town. You want to hang? Just shoot me an email.
You know what I mean? We'll chill. Get a pizza or something.
When Jersey guys put our on the end of pizza for no reason. They,
we got extra Oz here in Jersey. So we just try them on at a pizza's pizza.
You want a pizza? There's no oriented pizza.
I know we got these extra ours line around all over the place in New Jersey.
Can't stick them on the end a much. So we just stick money into pizza. Anyway,
email me if you want to re mail me, huh? What's that? Ah,
we got an extra, we threw it on the beginning of the email.
Remail remail me some pizza. All right. Next one.
Conceded.
Ah, your dad died early.
Somebody wrote me once and they were like Insta. I'm a huge fan.
You might want to think about saying,
not saying your dad died early because my dad did die early and every time I say
that, I get a little sad. Why don't you say your dad left early? So okay. For,
you can see to me girl wanted, Hey dude.
Dad left early. That actually might be funnier. Lou.
Oh,
the body of this loser available.
Ah, loser,
mailable dude.
Grow up.
Hey dude, they'll push up.
Yes.
These are available. Also lose available.
Like this guy just owns a print shop. Hey, what's up?
Lou's available for use and abuse in quotes.
Sid Jersey by conceited self-centered mean girl,
no sex or drugs, please. Just attitude. Call Steve.
Not going to give his number. Obviously. Of course his name's Steve
do not contact me on. So this is a resource cost. Steve, Hey,
loser available, dude, loser available.
The fact that he uses the word available to guide this guy,
he's probably a CEO of a company of a company.
It's probably a CEO of a company loser available.
Imagine being friends with this guy and, and meeting a conceded girl.
And she's just like, yeah, I just can't find a guy, you know? And you're like,
you know, I know there. I know there's a loser available.
I can insert to my, I could introduce you to my friend, Steve.
He's interested in use and abuse.
Really? Yes.
Wow. Your dad left early.
Your dad hightailed it early. That's amazing,
dude.
It's cool. How? Uh,
my back hurts. It's all good.
Um, I just like Shane West's Instagram posts on you. That's how it goes.
That's how it goes. That's how respectful I am on you guys. I wanted to do it.
I did do it.
And I did it because I'm respectful to you babies because this is a cult
and I am the way I am. And the reason why I am the way I am,
I can be the leader of this called and you're welcome for liking Shane.
West's Instagram posts during this podcast.
You're listening to during this job that I have guy with LA hat in
Belmore, Belmore area. Anyone know this guy. He is so hot.
Always walking with a girl, I think is his wife. Safara not that I care.
It's a disrespectful. If you see this, maybe we can get a drink together.
I am the blonde girl near fifth Avenue. So homewrecker,
Hey, anyone know this guy, LA hat in Belmar. He's so hot.
Walk with the girl that gets his wife.
Don't give a trying to wreck his home to not contact and getting unsolicited
services loser available over here.
Just, wow.
I love these, dude.
There's so many problems with people. Deep seated problems.
Why does this happen though? Still that happens. It didn't.
We stopped that or no, no. We stopped this where it comes forward.
This mic stands sucks. It's all good. But to some extent sucks.
Yes.
It keeps going closer to my mouth and falling down. Oh yes,
dude. It hits my face. Yeah.
Whoa. Everything.
Everything I need in this podcast is all right here and it goes away.
I don't want it.
Yes.
Next misconnection mechanic needed probably not.
Let's check looking for a mechanic to help me out and likes to play too.
No older than 55. Like to play to wrong,
to no older than 45 minutes street guy looking for another discreet guy.
Please mess me for nothing yet. You don't need a mechanic.
You need to bother me. Oh God don't need a mechanic. Need a shrink.
[Inaudible].
Mechanic needed looking for a mechanic to help me out. Likes to play too.
No older than 45. Doesn't need a mechanic.
Oh God don't need a.
Mechanic. Just need to sit down for an hour a week. All.
[Inaudible].
I kill it, dude. I should be in the new aerial movie.
Why are people so off she's was she black? Who gives a? Dude, she's a mermaid.
She's not rail.
I'm surprised people. Aren't saying well, it's disrespectful. Of course,
to give the mermaid, the black course can't be a regular human. It was a,
but June I'm surprised that that didn't happen.
Of course people are always like, Oh, you make the purple guy black.
[Inaudible].
I'm surprised people aren't off. They will be,
Oh yeah. When they made will Smith not blue. And then they made him blue.
Of course.
Hey guys.
Down for a week. Sit down for an hour a week.
Hey guys, chill.
Step Tweeten and sit down.
For an hour a week.
I like how I'm calling people crazy. And in the beginning of the podcast,
I said, I wanted to make out with people that talk to close to me.